in the event of a fire emergency please
exit building normally manner to which
up before in this room is indicated by
the green bar exit signs please do not
delay the evacuation by collecting any
belongings do not use the minute the
premises must not be reinterred to the
follower gage has given you all clear
please note to pit it against the
lobsters - thank you
please note that the meeting will be it
will be recorded and comes remind
everybody president or either turn their
mobile phones off water and it's a
silent please thank you vitamin one
which is apologies for absence in power
quality from counseling Milne Council of
Gooding and counselor Newport where
apologies my turn I'm too to substitute
members we have councillor Griffin
substitute for council meal and council
Weston or council gooding members
it
item number four minutes the meeting
held in the center than those shown
above which have been separates members
505 to receive declarations of interest
okay
this happened a presentation circulated
to us by email and seven members of our
caucus as well so we have had a chance
to thank you thank you very much and so
thank you for the opportunity to come
and yes give you an update as you say
since February what we've been doing
around our development program and most
I met my advice people around the room
but for those if you've not met before I
am the managing director and the factory
within Rockford area held that position
since 2009 but I've worked with actually
in the district now for just over ten
years we managed just over 2,200
properties in the district may have done
since the stock transfer from the
council in 2007 and the majority of our
property are vented general needs or
family housing with about 400 properties
for older people and
just a handful of shared ownership
properties and we do apologize that we
weren't here at the November meeting
which in jutsu will fail or hell and as
you've seen we've prepared a short
presentation which we will run through
but we are happy to take any questions
at the end of time
and so there's patter a bit looking
around to Chris Cole is going to take
you through the presentation Thank You
Forrest artifacting just backcomb Emma's
apology for missing the last meeting
that many thanks for the invite to
attend tonight again I think many of
many of you are here earlier in the year
when we presented so presentation
tonight follows a similar format with
updated figures and few more updates on
some of the sites which are now
non-confidential from from our side so
if I can start start obviously with with
the successes today we we've delivered
153 new homes in the district to date
here's just a few examples there of some
of the schemes that we have delivered in
the last year we've been working hard to
build on that and increase the numbers
in the last year we've we've got three
new sites into contract where we we now
either own the site we've got legal
interest in the site and between these
three sites will deliver an additional
137 properties the first one of those
Sciences anchor Lane I think anujan this
is the site we've acquired
we've got Geoffrey Holmes
tractor they were currently on site they
have undertaken environmental and
ecological work on the site and are now
beginning the construction of new homes
up there and that would be live
certified new properties the second site
is bullet hole so we've now applied the
site of the former prison this year
we're currently on site with a
demolition contractor who's knocking
down the prison building and that's due
to be completed early in the new year we
have submitted the reserved matters
planning application and we're in the
process of selecting a contractor
subject to getting a satisfactory
planning consent to start construction
of new homes and then the third site is
Polly Lane and hotplate this is a
section 186 where we we are the
preferred RSL partner and we're in a
contract with the developer there which
will deliver 24 new affordable homes and
we're anticipating taking the handover
of a new properties and having those
available proper patient in the new year
in addition to acquiring land we've done
a review of our existing asset base as
well and we have three sites we're
progressing with the first one is Harris
Court in Hockley we've obtained a
planning consent this is small block of
garages we've got Payne planning consent
now four to two new properties on that
site and the second site is Kimberly
Road where again we have
planning consent for six new properties
there and final site is also an weighing
canoed and where we have a planning
application submitted for six new
properties there and I understand the
determination date for that has now
moved to the end of January in terms of
beginning construction on those sites
because they're all relatively small
we've had to procure them as a package
to get get efficiencies so we've gone
through a tender process we're waiting
for the planning consent forms online
and then we will be able to get into
contract with the contractor to to start
the construction of those view
properties there's just the one on the
right there these are the new properties
that we have different sentence or a
paragraph on the left in terms of sites
to where we're currently in negotiations
on that can talk specifics about that I
can give you a general update on where
we are
we've Greek terms on two additional
sites which will deliver 122 new
properties and we progress in
negotiations contractual arrangements
with the landowners on those we we have
another two sites where we run with
progress in negotiations but we're not
yet at the point of having legal
agreements in place and we've made
another two offers on two sides which
would deliver a third and ninety-four
property so just to summarize those
figures we make to you today we have a
hundred and fifty three properties
we're in contract on 137 apologies are
doing things up in the presentation but
we're having a
five properties which we've agreed terms
on through section 106 agreements with
with developers in the district with our
existing assets there with another 14
units with green terms one hundred and
twenty two and then we have another
eighty-seven under negotiation and
offers made on further 94 which if all
the loan is come to fruition with
deliver 692 new units in the in the
district that's a brief summary if
anybody's got any questions I'm happy to
rusty could I have a copy of the
presentation I don't seem to have one
which would be helpful if there is one
available secondly just a couple of
queries periscope came around for the
film why small developments yes we're
all aware that developments under
assessment size don't necessarily
provide but we would quite any call
affordable housing I'll have houses for
the Housing Register however you've got
a greatest need in the district these
poor houses that are open homes that are
available to residents on our Housing
Register could you tell me of any of
these small developments will be made
available through that or whether you
intend to serve them or read them
privately
yeah I can only on the existing assets
um quite happy to tell you it'll tell
you what our thoughts are on that
as you say dealing with smaller Sciences
is very inefficient
can be very costly there's the price of
actually developing them as we have
these land assets in the district and we
have the commitment
that's why we've gone ahead and look to
to develop on them the two properties at
Harris for Irene mass being rental
properties and the the six accompany
Road and the six homes on way earmarked
the shared ownership at present could I
just come back on that you say Harris
called rental yes
thank you thank you mister challenges
okay ship me back in 2007 the rotten
tenants have the opportunity to bug
whether to study abroad for housing or
come over to the sanctuary gurus they
have a part of the presentation or page
or from century and possibly Botsford
housing as well they essentially were
going and we've had the kitchens
bathrooms
except for etc etc part of of the hitch
was a mention of five hundred homes now
I think that the tenants was very misled
thinking that the five hundred homes
were going to be for social housing now
out of the five hundred homes that is
earmarked what you're going to build how
many of them homes are going to be for
social housing okay all I can do tonight
is give you a rough indication of
how how that may may look I can't I
can't give a specific answer on the 500
for two reasons the first reason is
we've been within the project within the
692 there that the final mix will depend
on how those possibly the final sights
that are under negotiation and offers
made come out and the second issue is
for the last year or two we've been
working under an affordable housing
policy which has been driven very much
towards shared ownership in the last
couple of months the government has made
a number of announcements about moving
the program or the emphasis of the
program towards additional rental
properties which impacts on how these
numbers overall get delivered we would
estimate at the moment that somewhere
between two-thirds reporters of those
units would be for affordable housing
mr. chairman Vanya you know I wasn't
read our percentages but I really wanted
to know because of that our housing list
and watch the district I would prefer to
number so you know could he get that
number next one
let me come we did we do 3/4 of 690 that
would be in the region of
the master 500 and 500 in something
properties 500 and something properties
will be put aside these social hours of
rentable affordable housing no it's a
rent and shadows if what I asked was for
social housing so people on our list can
go over there and rent from you okay in
terms of our in terms of our program
going forward because we we have to work
within the government guidelines and the
government framework and as I said for
the last few years that has been very
biased towards shared ownership and
that's where the government has been
putting the emphasis and hence the
reason why our program has an emphasis
on on shared ownership as I said in the
last couple of months the government's
been making announcements regarding a
readjustment back towards rental
properties and that is something as an
organization we're we're looking to
deliver all so it's very difficult
difficult at this point in time to
actually give an exact number of how
many would be for rent and how much
would be for shared ownership because it
will it will depend on the program and
that we can agree with the government
which is just one more question just one
more question and this has come up my
tenants have a something many times
there's to rent structures in rockford
district they could be the same house
opposite sides of the road one side of
the road is paying half of what the
other tenants playing can you explain
that I'm assuming you can you be
referring to social Renton
so friend no I'm talking about social
housing yes so so social housing is
level is level two funny so some of all
and social housing is on a social web
which is about fifteen sixteen twenty
nine PM n and some of us is on
affordable rents which is up to 80% of
them are queuing so that's the existing
situation for attendance at the moment
and that's because it was built in a few
years ago the council the government
brought in affordable rents and a higher
rate so that additional money recharge
it without these fashions there into the
development program so we like many
other registered providers already
letting some activities in our weekly
skills portfolio on affordable and fun
developments and that's been the line of
still decreasing problems from central
government so that's why you could have
to exactly you know 250 very executive
famous door to each other
one might feel actually is go on social
web one life been letting the last
couple of years more affordable and so
it's actually the government that are
deep tightening rings but I'll friendly
circulated by the governmental directive
is regulated by the government
I'll target around how much we can
increase or decrease comments by every
year regulated registered fine with
social housing so as a non profitable
company you could have 50 percent less
than the market value of Brent further
there's a way of calculating
well I like this one it loves thank you
very much thank you
I'm to agree what my question I think
it's been obviously has a clear ask the
question as we discussed earlier so but
it's trinkets and are still so just
going back to the number of new homes
and whether or not they were foldable
and you're talking about whether or not
they're going to be shared ownership or
or or a full range obviously you're not
saying you're not going to adhere to our
councils policy where if it's a if there
are affordable houses built under a
section 106 agreement that they're going
to be a tips in the form of rent and 20
percent shared ownership are you
referring to ones which might be that
for instance you've got the hair is
called will be are not going to be part
of a sector 106 screams that's your
choice to build those isn't it yes I
think if we understand how many of the
692 are ones you've chosen to build as
affordable and how many will be
affordable because they're part of a
section 506 agreement I think I know you
because some of our under negotiations
and offers of I would say is that again
in broad terms under the policy 35 don't
have to be affordable there's no
question that we will not deliver that
so where there's a 35
the housing requirement we will deliver
that of the 692 with all the three of
our existing assets and then probably
maybe about another ten in there which
wouldn't be subject to a section 106 but
that we will still deliver out as
affordable housing so there's probably
about 25 units there which will all be
done for affordable and then as I say
overall it's going to be somewhere
probably between about 2/3 and 3/4 so in
addition to the 35% we'll be delivering
another 30-40 percent affordable housing
okay thank you so I'll step on on they
have this struggle through the other
questions are either how many of the I
suppose this this two figures he I
suppose ups that terms agreed 511 I make
that if we go Daniel yeah and then we've
got another figure of 692 how many of
the up to the terms agreed would you
expect to be delivered by March 2018 and
by stated week I should say wait with
exotic agent would we're pushing to have
those all in contract fine art yeah the
511 years I like it and the 692 would be
sometime after that cool yeah directly
best of wishes for Logan's if it could
have 2200 properties about the money in
the district What's Up sir did you lose
he is through right and I can't be
difficult we've lost since and since the
stock transfer and had but if two three
four something like that generally and
if we have reached it happen to be my
guest but we could certainly check that
figure 48 revision history so I just
wanted to $4,000 city house its
properties yeah I think if we are [ __ ]
and how are the trades of seaweed in
that there's been pinks and 12 stars i
forget so we could be consenting I think
for us it's probably not been and as
high made is we would be perspective
there's a four-handed have you done any
survey or assessment as to how
affordable in rental terms properties
are that you will bring forward in
relation to the average income someone
living in district okay I don't know if
you want from purely from from from my
perspective the rent we charge is
dictated to us it's not something we we
have any flexibility on so the
affordable rent and they've got
see is 80% of the market rates and that
80% included service charges and any
other cost that would be associated with
the property do you have any any
indication as centage of those people in
those affordable properties we are
getting subsidized through forms of
government sort of an added benefit or
top-ups from various different schemes
and things like that have you got any
indication of yeah yeah I mean I could
go be difficult to answer that stuff
might I think the only thing I've just
started on the thing the rents or
suspect the LH a cat so we do cap
Hollings you know in calculating events
in line with LH a camps and yeah I mean
I can't give you a figure or third stuff
my head okay but it used to be if I
don't know what it is at the moment they
used to be about 70% of people would be
in the seat of some level of benefit but
that could be you know a few pants up to
fully benefit but again that's only
something that's I mean unless Louise's
team as grainy and further informations
all night
just generally that has an optional
parameter you can see just the
affordability factor you know you know
in rockton you know market when useful
times the amount of people's income
generally but I can't talk any further
is that something that you're going to
be looking at to keep up keep up to date
so you've got an understanding of who
the attendants are and where they are at
where their difficulties may be with
girls to afford in their rents going
forward but like I certainly said that
every month before an attempt moves into
a property we do mobility check on them
so and so we do a tweet tenancy visit
all when we do them and we do a
financial and military check with them
and so that when if within the people
made in claiming benefits all thing that
they're entitled to and we would talk to
them about that we did they're going to
struggle scale event you know we will
talk to them about what's you know what
that means for them I think because we
are the mainland also in the district
but we don't do it safely
we won't take them balanced and cool
real problems to the council if you've
started saying I'm going to take her
home as tenants we can make a deal based
love we don't think we can afford it
there really is more about working with
our colleagues and the council with our
income
ability the things that we do track of
things like a number of interconnected
and I and the and spare room sedated
people's were affected my benefit counts
and that's an information so that would
flag to us as a risk and the movie
worked closely arming come advisors and
I mean come welfare officers would work
closely with those families and analysis
so we certainly had been risk management
process in place and make sure that
we're supporting training for how many
work with that you know the
organization's I family my saying it
could be support obviously if something
has been in the press and discussions
about the introduction of the Universal
benefit is that had an impact and are
you being a little bit more suicide
relaxed with some people because they've
got difficulties in transferring over
from one thing to another
was that not like not actually impacting
in this area alone and I think for us
it's not really impacted we don't have
very many customers alone in one
universal credit but when the full
rollout takes place in May next year
that's from
let's pose for us there the rollout of
our Universal Credit has been fairly
slow within this district you know it's
been relying - actually it's been
tonight it's been fairly strong in this
district but do you have some customers
coming through it may be I believe
people have been homeless and suffering
times Universal Credit and they swap
those fairly limited in fact at the
moment having said the ideas are too
hard to expect here is to substantially
increase and also the government
announced and honestly they hope stir to
cover the length of time for people
being assessed we would always take
things I signed a calendar you know
there comes up you have no
responsibility for death so I think if
we can see that doing everything to try
and you know they put their claim in and
they provide for information and they
sell it and they can you meet we know of
this is inspected but I think if you've
got situations where other people are
quieting and engaging with 11 agencies
so we were internet just wasn't
following and the budget announcement
now back to general if I might come back
tonight another question mr. chairman
thank you know I might be missing
something here and with understanding it
and I'm thinking you've answered the
question but I'm not sure that I take
the other study it so forgive me if I
put it another way
I'm coming back to the splitter going
between rental and shared ownership and
I understand that you can't be precise
that the an element of it and you were
saying indicating two first two three
quarters would be rental it seemed quite
hard high amounts of shared ownership
are any of these properties that you're
showing in here not for shared ownership
but not for rental I any of them for the
private yes yes how many so the
two-thirds to three-quarters is what we
call affordable which would be a mix of
rent and shared ownership and then the
remainder would be market sale so you're
okay okay thank you
thank you
due to the fact that there seems to be
an increase of publius homelessness in
the district and we have already been
told that we foresee a few rising
figures I'll be secretary rented it to
the district other districts that want
to come here so much - why are we
these thankfully ready to bring tener or
legend ere the properties - - so I saw
other other councils not the case or
anything like that
only four is it basically for the
district of Rochester so the properties
that we left and most of them will be
subject to a nomination agreement with
the council where hundred percent of
first let's that we have a value new
scheme 100 percent of those first rates
will go to the council and then when
vacancies come up issues just 75 percent
of vacancies will go to the council so
they're going to be people nominated by
the council for them from their list and
those remaining properties we can let
people from our own list and the
majority of people on our list are going
to be people and for Germany's for
family properties are going to be people
would probably lose wiping into a larger
prophecy or move to a smaller property
so they're likely to be our existing
customers for our housing for older
people scheme again and proportionately
those people going to be
all existing tenants already and there's
usually quite a lot of overlap between
kids on the council's and Housing
Register and who isn't
thank you just so money to a minor one
to them we've got here talk to the six
hundred ninety two earthy has changed
very much since the cosine 60 original
very mature we say there were some
additions made have you got any plans to
continued development again the Vet Wrap
district on for housing in the future or
future
absolutely I think probably the keep the
key the key update from the previous
meeting to this why is the fact that a
lot of the schemes of moving forward hmm
so we're getting more progressed on them
we have had a few here a couple of sites
which come on and I'm aware that there
will be some more larger sites that will
be coming through during during the
course of the early part of next year as
well and it is our you know it's not our
intention to to hit this target and then
stop what we want to do is maintain
momentum and maintain a program going
forward and it's you know at sites
coming forward you know we will look at
those and do our best to secure them
yeah it's rough you've mentioned forty
laning here that's a relatively small
sign relations to some of the sites
which one
yeah really be coming forward I think we
should say are you in a financial
position you could offer to build on
some of these sites where there could be
a 150 200 yeah absolutely I think
you know what what I would say that
there's two issues there so so folly
lane is a section 106 where we take them
to 35 percent affordable what we've been
doing another site such as bullet hole
is actually going into the market and
acquiring the whole site so that we can
control the full full development and we
additional affordable in there as well
so yes we will continue to look for the
section 106 is our preference is to
actually try and secure a hundred
percent of the site in terms of our
capacity we we have capacity for
delivering over 3,000 new homes a year
across the country rupture is a priority
area for us so there's no issue with our
overall financial capacity subject to
each scheme being financially viable
which is where where the big process
comes in and in terms of delivering
larger sites we're more than happy to
look at the larger sites we have we have
looked at larger sites some successfully
someone's successfully I think that the
benefit of a larger site is it gives us
a pipeline over a course of say two
three or four years which gives us
certainty for for delivery so you know
our preference would definitely be to go
down that road where we can where we can
secure the sites that have you a policy
around discount to two homes this was a
new one to me fairly recently which I
understand some builders are now
introducing which is broadly based on
the government proposed oddly but
they're the own given of his proposals
have you heard of this it's very enough
for us kids and scared homes
so whereby you as a builder may decide
to build some homes put a comment on
them that they could only be sold with
these certain restrictions such as
people who live within a mile of rainy
town center for instance and you that
may then sell them a 20 cent discount
okay it's not so if you come across it
very recently some developer I think our
main our main focus on that would be
would be the shared ownership product so
a name the number of developers really
106 is been trying to renegotiate out
this shared ownership but for the
discounted sell product in which is what
we're as we would look to secure that
continuity of affordability through
through a shared ownership I've got very
quick questions but I'm just jumping
fine things you've touched on any of
this one of them is the one we'll see
possibly if you bring ability of future
science is it a concern it's certain
district yeah I mean I think maybe the
course in the last ten years a number of
the large development planned sites have
come come through the market and that's
where a lot of the opportunities have
been arising I guess the question going
forward is is now now those sites have
been secured and are being developed it
is where the next next set of
development plan type sites come from so
I know some of the site of in the
development plan were earmarked by 2022
for delivery and that they've been
brought forward earlier and I suppose
our question would be the development
plan needs to have other sort of
strategic sites sitting behind those
thought for the future and
wants to deliver the housing if if those
sites come forward in development plans
you know we would be more than happy to
to look at those yes I'm sorry another
question here mr. Kovic not my I was
interested to hear you saying just now
that in regards to ball with Hawaii
would be looking for additional
affordable man under the council's
policies 35% little so now you're a
registered housing advice supplier else
and obviously our greatest need is for
foldable homes so is it
are you suggesting that when you
purchase a site but you would consider
putting in more than thirty five percent
affordable that's is our requirement we
would look at that in a number of
factors same spec generic answer I'm
afraid is different so sometimes we may
look to put 100 percent affordable on
there some sites we may looked for 70 80
percent before belong there and some
sites we may want to be closer to the
35% section 106 affordable that's for a
number of reasons firstly is on one of
the larger sites we are competing with
house builders so we need to be
competitive with our bids to secure the
science and secondly is the issue around
affordability so if you took took bullet
hole for example if we put 100 percent
affordable housing on there that would
be a very expensive option for us and
secondly would be very expensive
potentially for the people moving in
there so what we what we would
potentially like to do is use that to
deliver additional affordable housing
which are more suitable for it I think
your answer and I'm impressed to hear
that you're going to put additional
affordable unit on that side we'll
consider again to 35 and then it depends
how government funding because I'm sure
thank you it's just a fun question at
the forward hold science the Hamiltons
that were previously occupied by the
present offices are they going to be
demolished so Tara Stiles is here yes
which were the former prison officer
houses they're all privately owned now
they have been sold separately but they
were previously sold right the plans
we've required is this area here there's
before McGurk a barracks area there and
then the site comes across here active
bullet hole and then the prison area and
another car park there so it's pretty
much what you can see on the plan here
excluding the these existing for at
least 30
presentation
we have attending this evening no new
for section one bought one for sir
Matt Bentley principal - officer counts
with Simon Smith - Thank You counselor
George I mean most to be present members
of the media here this
[Music]
absolutely good evening yeah it is a
fairly self-explanatory report but let
me just pull some key points if I may
first of all obviously we've recently
just had a base rate rise so if I can
point you to page seven point two in the
table in paragraph three point two just
just to kind of give you some indication
there on where base rate is expected to
go now that this these aren't our faults
these are the thoughts of our treasury
management advisors company link which
were formerly called capita Asset
Services they they're quite and they're
not saying there's going to arise until
December anything there are other people
out there saying that that rises could
come sooner and could be steeper but as
it stands we're going with all they're
saying their track record is pretty good
to be honest so I think you can pretty
much go by that having said that if
there is a rate rise of some good news
in terms of where we thought our cash
was obviously with this hopefully see a
bit of an impacting the accounts where
we where we brought our cash
if I can take you over to page seven
point three and paragraph four point
three when we brought the over every
year we bring the treasure manual any
strategy before yourselves before it's
then presented to fall council this
year's strategy is still in place but
we'd like to add in what's been noted
there are four point three to this
year's strategy to allow the council to
consider its options around financing
the trading company this is with regard
to the development of the three small
sites and phase government project
wyvern this just this really just allows
us to consider every option as we
continue the due diligence on how we're
gonna finance those projects so if
that's agree in fact is forwarded to
Council for agreement that would be
added to this year's strategy and then
will become part of the strategy next
year as well as we move I would
highlight that in four point four
currently we don't have any external
mooring requirement of the moment but we
will be bringing in to you in next
year's strategy it's part of the MTFs a
requirement to add external lowering
into the strategy for 2018-19 again to
give us those options around financing
any major projects they're coming online
for example project wiper
you could then turn to page seven point
five five six point three just part of a
flavor therefore where we currently have
our cash invested I mean as at the date
this repulse written thirty of set of
September we had eight million pound out
on investment and as you can see we have
three million there with Santander tied
up in 60-day account the other two
options there three million in liquid
bank calls fence coaches Swedish banking
and two million out of money market with
a prime rate money market they're both
instant access accounts so we can get to
that cash literally straight away I
can't give you an update if you're
interested as it stands today we have
ten point three million pound it was a
split out over those same three areas
there is an update to that where we're
now beginning to see on a daily basis we
get phone calls from a broker that we
use and there are lot that local
authorities now looking to or Akash to
lend between other local authorities
which is six year local authority or 100
percent government back to by writing so
and the rights that are being offered a
substantive substantial but they're
they're higher than we've been given
overnight in in spence for a moment so
there are further options coming on
stream finally paragraph seven just to
bring to your attention the current
contract and we link for we capita
- for renewal at the end of January next
year and in appendix the appendix that's
attached to this report sets out what we
would like to include in procurement
process this list has been put together
following a meeting with the treasury
management task and finish group
subgroup of this committee there's one
change to that since we met with we've
met with our portfolio holder councillor
Smith and it's councillor Smith view
that he doesn't want it doesn't feel the
need to be involved in those
relationship meetings that proposed with
whatever the advice and money is going
to be so currently we have two or three
relationship meetings a year which have
currently been just help it to myself
the one flag one officer in that
relationship
officer was dead can the support of one
of the movements yes sorry point one
yeah we did consider bringing portfolio
into those meetings but those meetings
to realize some more operational and an
hour bitching there's advice to us as
officers making those decisions there's
nothing else I wish to add so if there's
any question than that it's taken yeah
thank you very much for that overview
and you mentioned about Ryan
in relation to assets and investments
they sort of seed with news however did
during the future capsules looking to
borrow for some investments in the
future and I might have impact on you
know future forecasts in relation to the
connections I've eaten yeah
taken three point two there does some
printer does give you an indication
again this is this is minguk's view on
where to 5 10 25 and 50 public works
like world rates are going to go
having said that we rates are still the
lowest they've ever been at the moment
and but obviously if rates rate Bank
base rate does go up and there will be
an increase in those rate rises as I say
that the the rates that are put in this
table are the best indication we have at
the moment but that's not to say we
could all be sitting here next month and
bank giving in like the base rate up by
half a percent one percent then
obviously these rates will change in
term but as he stands with the base rate
being half a percent these are the best
imitation
thank you Thank You chairman so comment
on a couple of questions one of them
leads on from quit
you mentioned outcome being triple-a up
don't think a strictly I think it might
be a a plus just a point and that leads
onto a fixation regarding lending to
possibly potentially Green Gateway
trading Development Company Limited
premier definitely that is unlikely to
be a a plus as a brand new startup so
presumably a bear lending criteria have
to be relaxed for that as well
or is there point of this we can just
ignore the lending criteria to to lend
to our subsidiaries now we go subsidies
open companies or people yeah sure we're
currently going through with we've got
external advice being drawn up at the
moment on financial to diligence on your
options are investing into into the
training arm and so we're waiting for
that to come back yeah so I mean in
terms of the lenders for counterparties
we'd be looking to keep the assessment
most likely of keeping nice and travail
writings and what we might need to add
to the study at some point is an
additional bits about how we could lend
yet to our trading on and obviously
whatever if we did choose to go down at
Whitworth member approval we would have
to make sure that the rights we would
lend to the company we've let the
commercials or the risk so that's a bit
were taking advice and so we would look
for the right that which we learn to
reflect the the risk profile of what
we're looking to lend to so we would
probably set out sort of a separate part
of the investment strategy that sets out
the criteria that would apply to those I
think has referred to the report we
would have to take any business
investment decisions around that sort of
separately really
governance and and then make sure that
obviously our treasurer management
strategy going forward and adequately
reflects a different part of the
portfolio that were looking to invest in
but in terms of lending to our you know
I can't apologies outside but they're
trading on we would be looking seeing
their you know the risk criteria as it
stands at the moon that seen through the
chair for me I'm sure we've lent to
green gateway trading was that they're
not outside of our policy at the time we
did we don't call anything up we have
length yes I win Green gateway trading
Corral's maintenance was established a
loan of 25,000 I believe was provided at
the time which has now been paid back my
understanding that is that is a living
council policy
so it because that was approved of for
counsel that was therefore was done
outside of the treasury management
policy is that what we're saying well I
guess I guess it's we're looking at
people we're able to ignore it why it's
a loan rather than say I guess the way
to look needs because it submits
literature names line between Rajshri
District Council that's been approved
through investment more than full
counsel to the trading arm
whereas this is looking at every other
option that could be on the table in
terms of potentially buying equity in
the company whatever the option might be
I suspect we may have linked to the
company then without actually have a
look what's in place to do so yeah I
suppose it depends what perspective you
you look at it and that was more of an
operational line just to how the company
exists or sort of working capital line
to allow the company to operate rather
than a purely investments is room
whereas with it with these properties
arts were looking at we're looking at
them really to invest in and to generate
a commercial sort of financial return
policy for the green gateway trading
that's happened so far they've needed
some working capital to operate but it
hasn't been a sort of investment
decision in terms of we looking here
let's make a financial return as part of
our capital program so to be clear was
an interest-free loan with
now there was a return on it so it was
an investment leave my finger never
forget he went from that I think you're
just adding the the process however one
to describe whatever the name we want to
give to it if there's an informed
decision that it was it was a public
decision in scrutinized position through
counsel and since it happened it's been
through the audit process as well final
part which is around councillor Smith
and the decision not to attend the
meeting how will is there a mechanism
mechanism in place that the revolver to
report back button to counselors Smith
on what their meetings contained I
shouldn't there will be even if it's
just a report because I'd be a bit
concerned if you're not attending those
meetings and then nothing to miss
something because of it today as
mentioned the overall strategy of the
investment policy is what we're looking
at here the the relationship meetings
are very much operational the public see
my role being beneficial to more than
anything but nevertheless the overall
direction of travel of movements within
the the marketplace and treasury
management as a whole is fed back to me
and so obviously we have our regular
meetings and feedback mantra imagine
that and the the quarter reports and the
performance of the investments is all
part about that process thank you
just purpose room yes there was some
discussion between members prior to this
meeting and found the practice of doing
exactly what it's being discussed in
here
we forgot to move the government as to
whether business can you just clarify
for member what the current status is
and I'm assuming you're not anticipating
so it so I'm assuming you're referring
to the current government consultation
on being able to invest outside of the
local authority area possibly I think
others a general and sort of requirement
not to and for --'tis not too forward
borrow in advance of need unless as a
specific economic reason that you would
want to guess so I think at the moment
some authorities have taken the view
that in order to generate potential
returns I have looked to invest in a
broader portfolio potentially outside of
the local authority area and I think
that that is an area that central
government has potentially raised some
concerns around and that's what they are
as macro preferred to consulting on at
the moment so they're they're looking at
the sort of how the treasury management
sort of advice should be interpreted in
the strategies that people should use to
determine where but there should be
limits on what authorities can borrow
for so that's currently I think it's due
to end the consultation in a month or so
so we might get some more guidance then
but I would say it's probably in my view
it's unlikely that they would then stop
authorities borrowing for projects
within their own area which is what we
are suggesting
the lineman and one does it when you
would expect another come back for me
yeah so they're currently do to do an
initial report back by the end of next
week we'll see they're going to consider
it as office service and there's a
report that suits go back to the
investment board in January where we're
reporting these sort of outcomes of life
of that and our recommendations as to
next step thank you very much mr. Mason
Thank You Joanne I'd like to address
these questions to mr. Petri please can
I can you tell me whether there's any
amendments intended proposed to the
appendix that's attached to this report
the only proposed amendment would be on
item 1 so you remove that reference to
pull find out
so please Arabic that's why are you
making that an additional recommendation
yes yeah I think we'd like administered
that that change we're proposing you
know we would like to take that forward
so we will be removing in an inline
report photo holder and chair of
investment book so the meetings will
just be with myself head of Finance and
section one flight one officer
so it's am the chair chairman that's why
I'm asking the question because it's not
clear and now I've asked the question
we're now hearing a string of further
proposals can I just ask the belly just
make it clear what we're doing really we
will be making item one of fightin
paragraph one bullet point one of item
seven if the appendix will be the the
two strategy meetings a year will be
between the section one five one officer
myself head of Finance and whoever wins
the contract as relationship manager so
obviously we we understand now why the
finance same reasons I think
historically these meetings of things as
we've said all four select meetings with
that member involvement as we said they
are really for operational purposes
conformance strategy but obviously as
part of the treasury management strategy
that's agreed at the beginning of the
year and then these subsequent update
reports we do now and at the end of year
all that information gets fed in to
those and members to agree those so
there is a framework for sort of member
engagement and approval of our
strategies and our investment plans but
as we say these are ready to inform the
reports that members get so we didn't
feel it was necessary for members to be
present at those at those meetings
Sharon you continue yes what assurance
do I have that prior to the annual
strategy being put forward to this
committee because it will be this
committee what assurance do I have that
the both of the portfolio held for
finance and the chair investment board
have approved them before they come to
this committee
so I'm not forgive me I'm not being
totally difficult I'm not sure if I
understand the question with you hello
I don't want in this committee to sit
and make decisions on behalf of
portfolio holders okay yep so I want an
assurance that if they're not going to
be present in these meetings but at the
very least we have their tacit approval
of the treasury management annual
strategy before it comes to this
committee yeah we have regular and you
can confirm that and we community we
have not the meeting so we're all speak
to every fundraise report those three
counselors and the chairman of the
Investment Board because we are now
talking about borrowing we're not we're
not proposing tragic and is just about
borrowing in this year's but as we safer
if we put that in there for the future
strategy for 1819 yes we would engage
with canceled myth and obviously with
the chair investment order chairman
that's a minute able surance to to take
that recommendation forward in my
judgment as a member of this committee
I've got two other questions mr. petty
raised the interesting issue of other
counterparties which were a A+ which
were other local authorities are you
proposing that these become
counterparties within the current
treasury management annual strategy or
are you going to bring a payment a paper
forward as we've had in the past and
sadly be rejected for fresh
counterparties our current treasurer
major strategy allows for us to invest
with other local authorities in that
case chairman may I ask mr. Bedley to
explain to me why we're not because if
the returns are so much higher
then I want to understand completely why
we're not doing it because clearly we've
we've actually given up income valuable
income and and not and not security
further I would probably like to see a
paper because I have some doubts in my
own mind I hear the words it's
guaranteed by the government but I've
got a funny feeling that if a
counterparty failed to replace that they
probably at the government probably
wouldn't immediately like it would do
for banks wouldn't put their hands in
their pocket and give us the money back
and I've got a funny feeling we'd be
funding a borrowing at the public loans
board rate or even higher it may even be
a punitive rate because another lender
has to be found for us so I'm not too
keen actually on hearing that we can do
it already
a we haven't and we foregone income
which would have been higher and further
I don't think we've examined it
sufficiently okay if I may just take the
first point it's only recently that
sentences probably and within the last
three to six months that we've started
to get calls through our broker to say
that local authorities are interested in
lending between one another up until
that point the best rates we've been
able to get given our risk-averse
strategy are with the three institutions
that are named in this report given that
they are now within that within our
strategy they have things within within
our strategy for a number of years as
finance officers it would only be
sensible to start to look at them as
another option now the rights of tick
starters take up a little bit
in terms of government the question
around government support to local
authorities I would have to go away and
look at the vices of that but it is my
understanding and has been one of the
same as long as I've been in local
government financing that the council
the central government backs local
authorities in terms of financial
problems
chairmen out I'd like to see enough
before this goes into full council not
to this committee but certainly for full
council I thought they weren't backing
before the Icelandic government back to
a lot of people but actually didn't pay
them back for several years so I'm not
I'm not terribly keen on what I've heard
I'm not assured and if it's already in
our strategy I think it behooves us here
in this committee to ask the next
question which I've just done and get an
appropriate assurance around that the
other and it's not really a question in
certain observations so you can relax I
was really pleased that you will be when
we when we lens when the council lends
money to Green Gateway Development
limited but not only we're gonna have to
consider that propriety and probity
reasons what level of interest that they
have to pay but I think I heard that the
council will also have to look through
not only to Green Gateway as a
subsidiary of the council but more
particularly where the investment is
actually placed the money might be
placed with green Gateway development
but essentially it's in an asset which
is going to be
is going to be rented rented to tour
third to another party and you know
chairman subprime was a big issue in
2008 and I think it behooves us as a
council and certainly through through a
Treasury annual strategy and the
Investment Board to ensure that we
really know what risk we're taking with
the covenants that are ultimate behind
the money we're putting in it's an
observation unless of course you want to
tell me you're not going to do that
thank you
cancers back thank you
bring you to seven point four and six
point two over matter where we've got we
started off with a five million pound of
investment and one point no I did so in
the main column again the main current
can't seems to have become a new campus
actually got there so where's that gone
that's the difference and I know it's
not we like to make money but you know
where did you find the other three
meters so so so the nature there's
there's two parts to the question really
the nature of our cash flow cycle within
a month so by paying our creditors money
coming in from debtors and through
government ground warming there's always
a fluctuating balance on our current
current account as we expand so any
given time one day we might have two
million pounds in there another day we
might only have 100,000 pounds it just
the nature of time and payments and
receipts as any bank account or even our
home bank accounts another element of
that varies that of the 1.9 2 million
without having the papers in front of me
going back that far I would think that a
proportion of that has probably been put
out - that isn't required for short term
cash flow purposes we've been put out
for investment so that's why the 5
million has gone up to 8 million plus
there's been more money in during the
year that we've been able to put out
into into investment they subject to
cash flow requirement yes I think as a
general principle we would look to keep
the level of our current account above
what it needs to be operational purposes
because we obviously making a minimal
return on that so we would seek for that
in in other products that yield slightly
higher return and then it's not said
obviously just before example we make do
ourself pay run the balance would be
quite high so this is the it's just a
snapshot of time it really is - our
current account level but I think the
bigger picture is about the the bumps
across all of me and all of the year I
realized that we've got to have a
balance in there
my currently camera and what is them
okay so the minimum we keep in the
current account is what we don't we
don't keep a minimum in there basically
we just keep the keep it at a level that
is recover our cash flow requires on a
new genus it can vary from day to day so
if you took the 19th of the month and we
pay our preceptors and we pay our
salaries will need circa four million
pound in there but on another day where
there isn't any transactions going
through we can keep it a bare minimum so
it really is monitored on a day-by-day
basis in knowing what's happening
okay thank you very much thank you to
Jim I'd like to come back to the
proposed amendment are the offices and I
must admit I'm slightly uncomfortable
with it I can accept
councillor Smith's desire and wish I say
that he doesn't particularly because he
need to be involved in these meetings
and the current chair of the investment
board but we're doing a policy here not
for three months not the six months but
for a longer period and with all respect
to counselor Smith we have a new
counseling Mike he may not at that stage
be the portfolio hold it for finance the
chair of the Investment Board can change
and whilst I said that he said doesn't
see it necessary to attain I think we
should keep the option in there of those
people attending if they wish now I
don't want want to make an obligation on
the portfolio holder can but I don't
think we should exclude the opportunity
for future portfolio hoses whether it's
Elsa Smith or not I don't know I'm not
assuming anything has a sweet
how'd intention of this is is the for
this is for four years so I can
understand that you're looking at your
situation now but someone else in
holding that situation might have a
different perspective so what I'd like
to do is to make a suggestion that
perhaps compromises made a compromise
between the two suggestions
all right so perhaps we could just say
that they'll make the meeting with the
option of the portfolio holder for
finance and the Chairman I think that
first but attending the meeting should
nice I wish and attend it to that
because I don't want to have those
people excluded at all and that's
certainly the working party didn't the
so are you happy with that you know if I
wanted to go to that meeting then there
wouldn't be a problem anyway well I
think we need it worded in there because
that the amount of financial involvement
is going to increase with the activities
that the council is considering
undertaking and I think there needs to
be that's provision in there so that if
the portfolio holder whoever they are
which is to take it out and the journey
of this work we should take that are
they to do so so I would propose that
that's amending to cover that
eventualities and if I may just ask one
other question of you met when we were
discussing this report one of the other
things that we considered was that we
wanted and I can't sit in here forgive
me if it is that they procuring to me
for a period of four years or less we
launched I don't think it is in there
but we have agreed to go through
I don't if you want to actually be
included so that if that should be what
we want in the contract that we can
verbally agree that that's quite a bit
that kid under questioning goes back to
what the Chairman asked or perhaps just
to help me understand something around
that cuz obviously pre me in relation to
what you're talking about
about local authorities and how the
government is now looking at how they
they're dealing we've come there in
investments or are we basically saying
that these local authorities have been
looking to try to acquire assets outside
their area exactly is like it's not
assets in relation to your life okay
thank you think what ways yeah I mean I
think there's a number of authorities
have been investing a whole range of
things most commonly property and
property sort of funds but yet other
things as well maybe sort of solar farms
or other investments a yard authorities
have invested in a range of different
and sort of investments to make
financial return outside
that's it there's a possibility that
it's gonna be a bit more restrictive
going forward possibly yes we're after
work and if the guidance isn't
absolutely faster than my wishes are I
think they're sort of statements make it
a bit a bit clearer so I think at the
moment if authorities are to justify
that it's in the best knocking of
economic interests of local authority
they think you made that argument and
then invested in those and that I think
what started happening as there is a bit
more challenge about whether that's the
right way forward so that's what's being
consulted on at them at the moment and
it may be that the government do issue
the guidance around okay thank you thank
you Jim just a quick question on page
seven point three and the table under
five point one okay but remind me what's
the three hundred sixty thousand pounds
is on the revised latest and NVIDIA
forecasts for the general fund reserve
please
the former sorry the forecast for the
gen what the 360 yeah which has appeared
obviously premiere after February 17 so
the original original budget for capital
expenditure is 1 million just had 1
million thousand well I feel like
million pounds so the latest budget is
1.5 million pounds the increase is
regarding the IT migration expenditure
and had also circa 150
and hours worth of projects from last
year's capsule program that moved into
this new PICU mr. Mason
thank you chairman thanks for letting me
know it it's in in pursuance of what
Callaway was saying and I guess I'm
bound to ask this question because he's
triggered in my mind that there is this
review being undertaken of the powers if
you like and the advisability of local
authorities borrowing for asset purchase
and I just like to ask our officers
whether there's any risk that the
government may actually prevent us the
borrowing for property investment
purposes as we intend for project widen
I haven't made any indication about to
look at that that's the case I think in
my personal view I think that's fine
Dion likely and the moment local
authorities are allowed to buy for
whatever they've seen fit within this
the general boundaries of their own sort
of treasury management strategies and
which is to say something that I've
interpreted that it's within their remit
far outside of their area as well might
as I say there's no there's no
indication from central government that
they would stop us borrowing for
projects within our local area so I
think my view would be that's highly
unlikely
could I just answer the question if that
were to happen they might my concern is
how Mr Hammond looks at essentially what
I was brought up to them when I was
studying psvr and I guess the terms that
exists public sector borrowing
requirement it still exists at least in
them the minds of the Treasury with a
bunch of local authorities all going out
there and borrowing from the public
loans and works board yeah I imagine the
figures getting quite beef and I just
wonder
you know how Mr Hammond feels about that
figure just simply being a call account
for local authorities so assuming it's a
bit more than just a semantic exercising
it could be the economic exercise if
that were to be closed off to us in
terms of treasury management and angle
strategy because that's what I'm talking
about what are the sources of borrowing
could we get involved in as a local
authority borrow from other local
authorities oh but I'm not sure what
terms they offer us in terms of you know
will you lend to us for the next 30
years maybe not I mean are we are we
entitled are we able to go to the debt
market and raise all sorts of other
instruments acquainted with at least its
subjects our strategy and what we want
to do we are able to borrow from other
external sources we're not limited to
PWL be lending although the majority of
cases that has been the more favorable
rate which is why than most authorities
have fun with those there are obviously
a number of other products out there and
we would potentially be able to borrow
from other sources as well so obviously
as a saver that we know you like to
borrow in strategy and an assessment of
the risks and rewards around those so
yeah there is the possibility of that if
we wanted to I see that this isn't the
obvious formal statement but at this
stage we have no intention of pursuing
those directions of travel at the moment
sorry love what directions are travel
can you make it more something line
understand said to go outside the public
works at this moment in time that's all
that's the the examined and the
preferred route of finance and should
witnessed a degree we haven't agreed any
yet so don't glad you said that because
otherwise what you said earlier because
now
the Sun a lot like in a moment obviously
should government policy evolve then
that requires us to review our policies
and our strategy but one of the things I
want them to take away from this meeting
is over time the policy the strategy
that we've got that you're examining
tonight has has evolved as being fairly
risk-averse obviously there's starting
to be a little bit movement in interest
rates and there are opportunities to
take greater risks and potentially have
great returns but obviously you know the
key word is risk and I'm still taking on
board that the risk of birth strategy
from what I've been hearing and perhaps
the nature of some of the questions is
still very much in place and so that's
something I am taking forward from from
tonight can I respond to that too
because we do have a portfolio net
holder you know kind of talking about
policy that hasn't been made yet so no
no that's not absolutely because it
hasn't been made yet feeling if that is
you know what you're you're gaining from
from from this committee and if you gain
it from me then you're gaining it from
someone who had a professional career in
significantly banking with a civilian
levels of lending and I am not I'm not
pursuing a personal view on on risk that
isn't one that I had professionally
engaged with for 33 years there may be
others who were you know here in banks
who were quite happy to engage at high
levels of risk and we all know what
happened that I don't we so I'm not I'm
not working for
a commercial organization that can
afford to lose money and this is a this
is a public authority which represents
whose assets are represented by its
people and as such you know we have to
be thoughtful about what we can do to
protect their lives and interests there
are a lot of councils who are wandering
around with huge amounts of borrowing
and Southend isn't that far away and I
would just be very thoughtful about how
we engage in this process so if you hear
risk-averse it's for the benefit of our
residents can I just add to that that
the ants meeting our strategy and for
the local government guidance as a whole
the number one priority is always
security of our investments and
liquidity then followed by potential
returns obviously within that those
boundaries are asked there is still a
stroke for a range of investment
decisions to be made in terms of risk
and reward security is always the number
one kind of support to our treasury
management strategy okay Thank You
counsel
okay so just on that point again I think
it's a couple of years ago I think that
section 105 y51 office came over higher
risk policy which this committee didn't
approve and it wasn't changed and it's
not just a question of security because
you mentioned that that's the security
of the debt it was or the latency it was
also a question of liquidity of it could
be very secure in buildings and property
but could be very illiquid yes and could
take very many months to realize the
money so that was the other point we
made as a greedy at that time
30 questions
just quickly we've got two
recommendations here recommendation my
recommendation - just before could you
come back to counselor mrs. Mason its
recommendations if I am ultimately the
alteration to item one and I'm handing
seven if I could suggest some wording
perhaps that would help to come the
points that being raised so we would
read the tendons of two strategy
meetings a year
with the section one five one officer
and the head of Finance with the option
of the portfolio holder for Finance and
the chair of the Investment Board
attending should they so wish and then
carry on they should be hair size
justice ass very slight alteration which
I think covers both counselor Smith's
character and future proof set for
future people who may feel differently
should they be different members it's
over your backs of recommendation
just know that is with that situation
and there are important things to two
minute which I'm sure Michelle is picked
up thank you very much
it's all fun later
[Music]
just make sure you take your own coat
that means no fighting ability this item
is responsible for training so they
could just agree what is being presented
is this evening for the view cuisine in
October mean we did ask them to become
battles which they have done I hope
members of at Charleston had read there
are two
capistan if actually just a lady we put
absolutely and you know you guys to come
forward to talk about the the training
we've had quite a big discussion now
standards meeting committee and so we've
come up with some kind idea if you like
by although it's got working party i
think that we we decided to establish as
a working working party or working group
show you want to call it in the respect
of taking all four members of the
standards committee to to work out and
agree on a timely basis and begin their
very every year on the aspects of
training for members we talked about
having four members of the standards
committee across the board but I believe
in my own self that we've got the tough
love but we're looking at a couple of
very experienced counselors who've been
through lots of training for their many
years they've been calluses and possibly
to newer counselors will give us some
input input on some training and
development of accountants as in general
we're looking at it obviously at the
beginning of every I mean we meet when
useful yeah you never say maybe in the
autumn going forward I think it more
links explains quite a lot of it in here
there are aspects in here also about the
mandatory trainees but we also felt that
we should keep as is maybe a couple
couple little things that have changed
I'm not too sure Leo so I need to say to
saying that
I do believe all people was thinking of
one's myself why not believe this
counselor mrs. Mason being one of these
and the two other new newer counselors
counselor ed if I think he was one of
them must think we were trying FD sorry
colleges and I think we're going to try
and chat cancer Stanley he wanted to be
involved and also an independent person
so I think that gives us a wider choice
of training our own minds how we feel
good newer and older counselors I'm not
sure didn't he I'm not too sure why
we're going to set it on here because
obviously in standards committee we
could look at the training section we
apply we are recommending have to
explain what we're doing rather than I
think if I come in there yes generally I
think what's happened is this has been
copied from the eastenders committee
meeting MINIX which haven't been adopted
and as you're aware madam oh so chairman
here Cass domestic them we have
discussed it and they were actually
incorrect it wasn't a recommendation it
was supposed to noted and we discussed
that the standards and we wanted to
advise the review committee would work
it was being done because of the
concerns being raised but it was we were
advised by the officers and I think we
all
where the Santa's committee is a full
committee of the council and has the
right to determine the training anyway
and there was no need to make a
recommendation so unfortunately this has
come to remove committee before the
minutes adopted which makes it slightly
difficult so I think that's where we've
got the confusion of a date chairman
nevertheless I was like starting a
sentence with that better than so is
because I hate people who start with so
so so nevertheless it was this committee
this review committee their attention to
the fact that we needed to review our
training and this report in being at the
committee it's quite right and proper in
fact it would have been related
discourteous of the standards committee
to have simply said oh well thanks very
much we're now just gonna bypass you and
go straight to full council because we
can so I'm really pleased that that
discourtesy wasn't wasn't actually
delivered and we should at least know in
our minutes tonight that actually we
have received this report because of
their interest and involvement in asking
for this message to be to be perceived
so it's not quite as simple as some
people think
I mean I'd like to ask so each every
three years is through John really only
on a recommendation to full councilors
bill it's just a report to four count
John I just want to check we do how we
would that are going to be okay so just
a report to four counts with values and
recommendation to full council on the on
the training well page eight point five
to forty one this committee that's the
standards committee to consider
adjustments to the member training
arrangements and report its conclusions
through the review committee for onward
recommendation to full council hence
report because the status committee
considered through the affirmative
suggestions and
is now recommending through this
committee into council the last time
this committee met it was mindful by the
review committee that in many ways
member train is an important subject and
he recognized that although the
standards committee could resolve the
matter
it was minded to suggest that standards
recommend through this body into full
council I think we have a dynamic here
with the chairman for my mind that that
the review committee puts details for
that the blame cast Mason was the
council the boss for it however the
standard security did not agree and did
not think it's a subservient to the
review committee so it wanted to inform
the review committee advised that the
review committee of the work that had
been carried out advised that the work
that was proposed and inform for Council
but certainly the standards of community
diplomatic worry to recommend it to full
council and I'm sure if you listen to
the tapes that we've got people matter
and we did have officer a little at a
time this is not like the Northern
Ireland situation
I don't expect anyone to phone me now
and say I'm sorry but there's something
completely different and actually that
was a very good program
you know I enjoyed it hugely when I was
much younger look you know this can we
see is a is a grown up committee
standards committee is a grown-up tivity
when the council's pretty grown up I
hope the review committee and if you
listen to what I'm going to say the
review committee is is pleased to see
the report of the and recommendations of
the standards committee which is decided
to put two full council that is all we
need to do just like you do a mission
well I suppose it really ours if I I'm
happy to to recommend in a sense this is
you know we we told the review committee
exactly how we propose to do this and we
are coming back to just to let you to
say to the full council this is what we
are proposing to do aspect really
and it ended amid the death I mean I'll
be happy to go on this boat load that
wasn't quite intentional big thing when
you're shooting the dirt
it will just be noted it'd be nice to
save as activity we're really pleased to
about the report and to note the
intention of the Standards Committee to
put recommendations to for council I
think that's a really grown-up
like okay the first two items
11:17 economic growth strategy and 12:17
and discretionary base Valene published
reports have been issued and will be
considered that tomorrow night's
executives they should already have we
have four new ones
13:17 the brown feeling register 14 17
local housing options eventual inform
policy 1517 draft having
policy here created for consultation and
find these 1617 private sector housing
we also have social media and council
invitation process could be discussed we
suggested that the topic it's just what
it says I think it has to be made a
little more explicit that it relates to
mr. Kipnis is email in response to the
review committee asking what residents
wanted to talk about at the moment it
reads as if the social media policy that
is currently on the agenda for for
council on the 12th of December is to
come here but it isn't is mr. tip mrs.
letter and I think it needs to be
changed on the work plan so I get quite
clear it is mr. tip misses letter
certainly I'll make it clear on the
agenda I think frankly those the
council's internal social media that was
referring to yes
it doesn't quite say that at the moment
in that half my opinion
it refers to council's communication
process afterwards
so perhaps you should say counsel social
media wait turn on social media maybe
chairman you don't say the council's use
of social media because it's the council
using social media no one else anything
with the enforcement under the right
efforts between just remind me because
that says that was leaned to remote have
we asked him back for a report in full
because I couldn't see it on there yes I
did not accept that equation that's
right building control the interim
report has dropped on Friday beaming to
the buildings in trouble the one above
is the image that should be that one
should it then try this other online
yeah something wrong it makes more sense
to apologize yes I did remember
and then because that's only injury
let's go back up in June yeah Jim yeah
it's not specifically on the work plan
with the kind of related fingers it's
work is a work in progress as I
understand it seems to have died to
death for all very quiet in relation to
what's happening with the review of
Constitution I'm currently prodding the
assistant director to arrange a rating
on there's anything happened in this
current municipal you chairman I'm going
to ask you to do something about this I
think it's difficult for mr. Gowen to
prod an assistant director
I think it's not something that you know
we think we should ask him to do clearly
he's been prodding and clearly he hasn't
got any response may I ask you to have a
meeting with the assistant director and
find out what's going on please
any other questions or comments
I think I'd like to just cover that I
think it's a great concern that we've
got a working party topic that's been on
here month after month just being like
it's been a year